I love chicken nuggets I'm McDonough so
I'm really excited for this oh my god
mmm it's so good chicken nugget on a
stick I love chicken wings
I love McNuggets this is the baby to me
chicken nugget taste artificial it's
kind of like fainting me this is real
meal this needs to exist in America I do
like the exotic sysm of it and then you
pour it all over your fries I dig it
oh my gosh this is mine it kind of
reminds me of the Trader Joe's dry
seaweed I would like this if the seaweed
was in liquid form like ketchup and then
you shake it you know those Asian
instant noodles that you crushed
shopping you add the powder in it yes
it's exactly like that
I'm SP not show taste to it I feel like
with this you have to wipe your hands
all the time it looks like fish but I
think it's chicken mmm
this is fried and crispy patty and it
has pork belly and it tastes like bacon
what move are there's too much Mayo it
takes away the taste of that meat
we have like mashed potatoes or
something this is better than bacon oh
it's just really tender it's just really
good no no no no no
this is not good at all don't bring this
to the US so this is a chicken
pineapple chapada and it has cheese and
tomato it looks pretty good good
mmm Wow I take very Asian
it tastes like soy sauce this isn't as
hard as American Shabbat oh this is
really healthy so I taste like a
venomous sandwich with Chinese barbecued
pork I would need to I think this is a a
plus because this is from McDonald's you
would think that it's a bit watered down
but it tastes really authentic oh my
friend it's really good
hey so creamy like condensed milk it's
really foamy dang it tastes like stuff
at an actual boba shop it's not diluted
or watered-down if I were to freeze this
this would be like a green tea ice cream
Wow I would drink this for breakfast I
think all the flavors fit in Asia
because it's like more Asian
sensibilities like with the seaweed and
the crab I think it'd be interesting to
have it like maybe once a year in the
u.s. anything that'd be cool
I dig the Mik wings bring that to the
u.s. it's so good